[Music]
these
are doctor who fans arguably some of the
most passionate fans of any show
[Applause]
and this year they're especially excited
because for the first time in the show's
55-year history
the doctor won't be played by a white
british man it'll be a woman
this move adds doctor who to an influx
of sci-fi fantasy franchises who have
already
put women at the helm but this new woman
doctor is expected to have a trait that
those other heroines don't have
a sense of humor this is gonna be fun
for those of us not as invested in the
show as this guy
doctor who is the story of a mysterious
alien being
known as the doctor who travels through
time and space having adventures and
fighting evil
but the doctor has one particularly
special ability
when the character is mortally wounded
the doctor can regenerate
into a new body the doctor has had
13 different faces over the years all
white british men
this is one of the first episodes of
doctor who from 1965.
the doctor was an eccentric old man who
often relied on his more courageous
companions to get him out of some sticky
situations
in fact in early concept notes from one
of the show's co-creators
the character of the doctor was
described as a frail old man
lost in time and space but as time went
on and different actors rotated through
the role
the doctor went from being a frail
trickster to a male hero archetype
the third doctor in particular played
the role as an action hero
violent exercise makes me hungry don't
you agree
fast forward to the 10th doctor and the
action hero traits had become baked into
the character
leave this planet and never return
what'd you say yes there well then
thanks for that
but there's one particular personality
trait that stayed from the beginning
the doctor has a gleeful almost
childlike personality
he's a hero with a sense of humor which
makes the character fun and compelling
to watch
i'm the clever one you're the potato one
yes sir now go away yes i'm the doctor
by the way what's your name
rose nice to meet you rose run for your
life but that kind of character
complexity has been typically reserved
for male heroes
female superheroes are very much
pressure to be
taken seriously because there's so few
of them
they have to do well in 2014 the last
time good data was available
only 14 of mainstream sci-fi films had a
woman protagonist
women are not only vastly
underrepresented in sci-fi fantasy films
they're often restricted to generic
superhero personalities
if i think about the leading female
superhero
think about the wonder woman film where
she's powerful she's strong
but she's not a funny funny character
she laughs but she doesn't crack jokes
she doesn't
have banter in the same way that male
superheroes can do
that seriousness is consistent across
most women characters on screen
take a look at this scene between
guardians of the galaxy's heroine gamora
and one of the film's villains nebula
gamora puts up a pretty awesome fight
but compare that to peter
the film's male hero
things are gonna get easier notice the
difference
dance off bro me and you
there's also black widow from the
avengers whose whole personality is
built around being stoic
and katniss everdeen who can do some
serious damage with a bow and arrow
but barely ever drops your steely
persona of course there are some
examples
of funny heroines in film and television
one of the earliest is buffy the vampire
slayer
we can do this the hard way or well
actually there's
just the hard way these examples are
still rare on screen
but there is one medium where heroines
do have more complex personalities
female characters who do humor do very
well in comics you know
squirrel girl tamala khan gwenpool from
a financial point of view
it is less of a risk because there's
less pressure on
a female title to do well there's more
room for
comedy there's more room for humor
[Music]
it's this scarcity of women superheroes
in film and television
that makes the new female doctor's role
even more impactful
this woman doctor is not only expected
to be a great witty hero
traveling through space like her male
predecessors she could also push the
boundaries of what a woman hero can be
to have a female doctor that's a win for
a lot of us
women young girls will get to see
someone that looks like them
be smart and interesting and funny and
that
is incredibly important so even if
you're not one of the millions of people
worldwide who watches doctor who
next time you see an awesome new woman
superhero you might have the doctor to
[Music]
thank
[Music]
you